[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
CASEY RODRIGUEZ:
All right, so we
proved these two theorems last
time, and we used them for--
and we had a couple of
applications of them.
So the first theorem,
simple theorem,
was that a sequence converges to
x if and only if the limit as n
goes to infinity of the absolute
value of xn minus x goes to 0.
And then we also had the squeeze
theorem, that if you have two--
if you have three
sequences-- a sub n,
b sub n, and x sub n-- so that
x sub n is in between a sub
n and b sub n, and the a
sub n and b sub n converge
to the same thing, then the
sequence x sub n converges,
and it converges
to the [? common ?]
limit of a sub n and b sub n.
So x sub n gets squeezed in
between a sub n and b sub n.
Last time we used this to
prove a kind of special limit
that this equals 0 if
the absolute value of c
is less than 1.
So I had proved it for
c positive, and maybe
c less than 1-- but same proof
works with absolute values,
just because the absolute
value of c to the n
equals the absolute value of
c raised to the n-th power.
So let's use this
to do a few more
special limits if you like.
But first, I'm going to
state the binomial theorem.
I'm not going to prove it,
but it's a simple exercise
using induction.
And the binomial theorem says
that [? for all ?] [? N, the ?]
natural numbers, x, y in R, x
plus y raised to the n is equal
to the sum from k equals
0 to n of n choose k,
x to the n minus k y to the k.
And here n choose k--
this is equal to n factorial
over k factorial divided
by n minus--
times n minus k factorial.
OK.
So again, you can prove
this by inducting on n.
All right.
OK.
We have a theorem, so we'll
prove a few special limits.
I have a real number
that's positive.
Then the limit as n
goes to infinity of 1
over n the p equals 0.
If p is positive,
then limit as n
goes to infinity of p to
the 1 over n equals 1.
And the third is--
it's just that a
certain limit exists--
limit as n goes to infinity
of n to the 1 over n equals 1.
OK?
Let me make a
small comment here.
So far in our discussion
of the real numbers,
we've only defined what it
means to take a real number
to an integer power, but--
and n-th roots.
So we have n-th
powers and n-th roots.
So using that, we
can then define
how to take a real number
to a rational power--
although there needs
to be something that's
checked to make sure
this is well-defined,
because you can always write
a rational number not uniquely
as one integer over another.
So we can define a positive
real number to a rational power,
but using really only
the elementary facts
about the real numbers, the
fact that it has the least upper
bound property, and the fact
that the rationales are somehow
dense in the real
numbers, we can then
define what it means to
take a positive real number
to a positive real number power.
OK?
All of that is just to say
that to define a positive real
number to a positive real number
or to a real number of power
doesn't require the
introduction of the exponential
or logarithm-- although
they, in the end too--
they both agree, once you
do have the exponential
and the logarithm.
So all of that is
just to say that
what we've done up to now--
these things actually
do make sense.
You don't need the
exponential and the logarithm
to make sense of a
positive real number
to a real number of power.
OK?
But we're just going to use the
basic properties of exponents
throughout all
this, so we don't--
we haven't even talked about
continuity, or derivatives,
or anything like
that, so we'll just
use elementary means to be
able to prove these statements.
OK?
So for the first one, we'll
prove this actually just
using the definition of
the limit, which, remember,
means for every
epsilon positive there,
we should be able to find
a capital number M, such
that if n is bigger than
or equal to capital M,
1 over n to the p is
less than epsilon.
So let epsilon be positive.
Choose M, a natural
number, such that M
is greater than or equal to--
is greater than 1 over
epsilon to the 1 over p.
OK?
And if n is bigger
than or equal to M,
1 over n to the p minus
0, which equals 1 over n
to the p-- this is less than
or equal to 1 over capital
M to the p.
So here, again, I'm using--
an elementary fact
that we all know
is that, if I have a
positive power here, then--
and little n is bigger
than or equal to capital M
then into the p would be bigger
to the p.
We do know that for
integer exponents,
but just trust me that one can
define non-integer exponents,
and that inequality remains
true as long as the power
that you're using is positive.
So I have 1 over n
to the p is less than
or equal to 1 over
capital M to the p.
And by our choice of capital
M, this is less than epsilon.
So that proves number one.
So number two we'll do--
we really only need
to do two cases.
One is p.
So p equals 1 is fine.
This is clear, because
then I just get 1
for the whole sequence.
So that's one case.
Now let me do p bigger than 1.
OK.
And if p is bigger than
1, the absolute value
of p to the 1 over n minus
1-- this is just p to the 1
over n minus 1.
And so I want to show that
this quantity here goes to 0.
OK?
So we have an inequality
which we proved actually
in the second lecture, I
think, using induction,
but you can actually get from
binomial theorem as well.
So let me just recall
this right here,
that we had this
inequality that, if x
is bigger than or
equal to minus 1,
then 1 plus x raised to the n
is bigger than or equal to 1
plus nx.
OK?
And so we use this inequality
now with x equals p minus 1.
So p-- this is equal to 1
plus p to the 1 over n minus 1
raised to the n-th power.
I'm sorry. x is p to the 1
over n minus 1, not p minus 1.
And now we use this inequality.
This is bigger than or equal
to this thing times n plus 1.
So then I'll go over here.
So now subtracting the
1 and dividing by n
tells me that p to
the 1 over n minus 1
is less than or equal
to p minus 1 over n.
And as we noted here,
since p is bigger than 1,
this is bigger
than or equal to 0.
OK?
And now we apply
the squeeze theorem.
By squeeze theorem,
this is just going to 0.
p minus 1 divided by n--
that's just a number over n.
This goes to 0 as
n goes to infinity.
And in, fact that's
contained in number 1 for p
equals 1, and also
by our limit facts
that we proved from last
time, that the limit respects
algebraic operations
of the real numbers.
So by the squeeze theorem,
since this converges to 0
and this converges
to 0, this converges
to 0, which implies that.
OK?
So that deals with the
case p is bigger than 1.
To deal with p less than 1, we
use the case p bigger than 1,
and again, the fact that limits
respect algebraic operations.
Then we write the limit as p--
ugly looking p--
write that better--
the limit as n goes to
infinity up to the 1/n.
Now p is less than 1,
so 1/p is bigger than 1.
This is equal to the limit as
n goes to infinity of 1 over 1
over p to the 1/n.
And now 1/p is bigger than
1-- raised to the 1/n power
converges to 1 by the
case we did before.
And so 1 over this
converges to 1/1 equals 1.
OK?
OK, so let me just
remark that, although we
did prove this inequality for--
by induction, it
actually follows
from the binomial theorem.
And we'll use the
binomial theorem
to get a little bit of
a different inequality
that we'll use for number 3.
So for number 3, we
want to prove limit
as n goes to infinity of
n over 1 over n equals 1.
So rather than keep writing
n to the 1 over n minus 1,
which I want to show
convergence to 0 now,
I'm going to write xn.
So let xn equal n
to the 1/n minus
1, which we note is bigger
than or equal to 0 for all n.
OK?
And so my goal I want to
show is limit as x as n
goes to infinity of
x sub n equals 0,
because then that proves
that this converges to 0.
And since this is equal
to its absolute value,
that means that n to
the 1/n converges to 1.
And the way we're
going to do that
is using an inequality we get
from the binomial theorem--
and using this trick here.
Now, if we look at plus x
to the n raised to the n,
this is just--
that's just n-- let me
move it over a little bit--
plus x to the n raised
the n. x to the n--
x sub n is n to the 1/n minus 1.
Add 1.
I get into n to the 1/n--
raised to n, I get n.
Now, by the binomial
theorem, this
is equal to sum from k
equals 0 to n, n choose k.
And I have 1 raised to
the n minus k power, x
to to the n raised of the k.
OK?
Now, this is a sum of
non-negative things
because, x sub n is
always non-negative.
And these coefficients are
just quotients of factorials,
so they're always
non-negative as well.
This sum is always bigger
than or equal to 1 term
from the sum.
So it's bigger than or equal
to k equals 2 [INAUDIBLE] y2--
you'll see-- x sub n squared.
Now, n choose 2--
this is equal to n
factorial over 2 factorial n
minus 2 factorial x to the n
squares x of n squared, which
equals n times n minus 1 over 2
x of n squared.
All right?
Now, I started off
with n and I proved
it was bigger than or equal
to this quantity here.
So now I divide what's
in front of the x of in
and take square roots.
So then that implies that,
for n in bigger than 1--
because I need to
divide by n minus 1--
0, which is bigger
than or equal to n,
x sub n is less than or equal
to 2 over n minus 1 square root.
OK?
And now this is just 0,
so it converges to 0.
This right-hand side is square
root of 2 over n minus 1.
Now, the limit as n goes to
infinity of 2 over n minus 1
is 0.
Square root of that
also converges to 0.
That's a fact we did from
the end of last time.
So this whole thing
converges to 0.
So by the squeeze theorem, limit
as n goes to infinity of x sub
n-- which, remember, this is
just n to the 1 over n minus 1,
which implies--
OK?
And that completes the proof.
All right, so now we are going
to study a couple of objects
related to a bounded sequence.
What's the underlying question
we're going to try to answer?
Whenever something's
introduced, you
should think of it
in terms of, what's
the question that was asked
that this is trying to answer?
So we're now moving on to the
topic of limsup and liminf
of a sequence.
So here's the question.
So we've seen sequences that
don't necessarily converge,
like minus 1 to the n, but--
and we know about
subsequences now,
where you just pick
entries along the sequence.
You pick one, move to the
right, and pick the next one.
Now, if you look at
minus 1 to the n,
if I just look at the
subsequence consisting
of picking the odd entries--
the odd numbered
entries in the sequence,
then I'd just get
minus 1 minus 1 minus 1
for my new subsequence.
And this converges.
It's just constant.
Or if I chose the even
ones, I'd get 1, 1, 1, 1, 1.
And that converges.
So this sequence,
which is bounded,
has a convergent subsequence.
Now, not all sequences have
convergent subsequences.
For example, if you look at
the sequence x sub n equals n--
so x sub n is just 1, 2,
3, 4, 5, 6, and so on--
that will not have any
convergent subsequences,
because any subsequence of
that has to be unbounded.
OK?
That's pretty easy to show.
And we know that a convergent
sequence is bounded.
OK?
So what am I getting at?
So the question that we're
going to ask and try to answer
is the following.
Does every bounded sequence
have a convergent subsequence?
OK?
And what I was just
going on about right
there is that we
know this is true,
for example, for the
sequence minus 1 to the n.
We also this is true for
convergent sequences.
Convergent sequences
are bounded, so--
and they have
convergent subsequences.
Just take the subsequence
to be the whole sequence
to begin with.
And we have to throw
in this bounded part,
because there are
sequences that don't have
any convergent subsequences.
Like I just said,
x sub n equals n
is an example of an unbounded
sequence that doesn't have
any convergent subsequences.
So the answer to this
question, as we'll see,
is yes, this is a very--
really a very
powerful statement.
And this is due to
Bolzano and Weierstrass.
And I'll restate
it in a little bit
when we get to the
statement of that theorem--
namely, that every
bounded sequence does
have a convergent subsequence.
There are several different
ways to prove this theorem.
We're going to prove it by
introducing limsup and liminf,
because these are also
two important objects that
arise in analysis.
So let's get to the
definition of these guys.
So let xn be bounded sequence.
And we define-- if
they exist, there
are going to be certain limits,
so it's not clear that they
exist at all to begin with.
But we'll show that
they always do exist.
We define limsup x sub n.
And sometimes I'll write n
goes to infinity underneath.
Sometimes I'll just
write limsup or I'll just
have an n underneath it.
This is supposed to
be a number, and this
is equal to the limit
as n goes to infinity
of a new sequence obtained
from the old sequence x sub n.
What are the entries
of this new sequence?
This is sup of x of k, k
bigger than or equal to n.
OK?
And the liminf is similar,
except it's now with infs.
OK?
So for each natural
number n, I take
the supremum of the set
of elements x sub k for k
bigger than or equal to n.
So this is a bounded set
because the sequence is bounded.
So this the supremum is
well-defined-- same thing
for the inf.
OK?
So I get a number, a
new number for each n.
OK?
And I take the limit
of those numbers and I
define one to be the limsup,
one to be the liminf,
if they exist--
because limits
don't always exist,
so it's not even clear that
these two limits actually
are meaningful.
And the first
thing that we'll do
is we'll prove that these
limits do actually always exist.
So rather than keep writing
this, I'm going to give these--
write some symbols
for these two things.
So let a sub n to be--
so of course, if I forget to
say this at least in what I'm
talking about with respect
to limsup and liminf,
I'm always talking
about a bound sequence.
But let me continue to state
that as one of my hypotheses.
Let x of n be a
bounded sequence,
and let a sub n be the supremum
of the set of all elements
x sub k, where k is bigger
than or equal to n, and b
to be the infimum of x sub k,
a bigger than or equal to n.
OK?
So then there's
couple of statements.
One is that the
sequence a sub n--
so let me just
put over here what
these things have to do
with the limsup and liminf.
Then the limsup of x sub n--
this is defined to be the
limit as n goes to infinity
of the a sub n's.
And the liminf of x sub n-- this
is defined to be the limit as n
goes to infinity
of the b sub n's.
OK?
What we're going to show is
that the limit of a sub n as n
goes to infinity of a sub n
exists, and the limit as n
goes to infinity
of b sub n exists.
So how we're going
to show that is we're
going to show that
a sub n is monotone
decreasing and bounded.
And so these are
the conclusions.
So [INAUDIBLE] should say then.
The sequence b sub n is
monotone increasing and bounded.
So in particular, since
we know that, if we
have a monotone sequence which
is bounded, it has to converge,
that means these
two limits exist.
And then the second
part of this term
is the simple statement
that the liminf of x sub n
is less than or equal to the
limsup [INAUDIBLE] x sub n.
OK?
OK, to prove one--
so in fact, before I
prove this theorem,
let me prove a small
simple theorem first.
Let's put the proof
of this theorem
on hold just for a second, and
now prove a very simple theorem
that, if A and B are subsets
of real numbers, A, B,
both not equal to the empty
set, and is A subset of B--
so also need to be bounded.
So if we take two non-empty
subsets of real numbers,
such that [INAUDIBLE] bounded
and A is a subset of B,
and the conclusion
is that the inf of B
is less than or equal
to the inf of A.
And this is always less than
or equal to the sup of A,
and this is less than or
equal to the sup of B.
So what this says is that,
if I take a subset of B,
then that increases the
inf and decreases the sup.
OK?
So the sup of a
smaller set is smaller
than the sup of the bigger set.
And that inequality
reverses for infs.
The inf of the smaller
set is bigger than
or equal to the inf
of the bigger set.
All right?
And this just
follows immediately
from the definition
of sup and inf,
so I'll just prove
the sup statement.
So since sup of B is
an upper bound for B,
and A is a subset
of B, this implies
that sup B is an upper bound for
A. Sup B sits above everything
and B. A's a subset of B, so
it sits above everything for A.
Now, the supremum of A is
supposed to be the least upper
bound, and therefore, if I
take any upper bound for A,
that has to be bigger than
or equal to the sup of A.
So since sup B is an
upper bound for A,
this implies that sup A is
less than or equal to sup B--
and similarly with the infs,
so I'm not going to write--
so similar for infs.
OK, so let's go back to
the proof of this theorem
here, that if I have
a bounded sequence,
then the limsup and
the liminf exist.
And we show that by proving
that these two sequences have
these monotonicity properties.
So proof now of the
theorem we were--
started off proving--
OK.
Since the set of xk's,
with k bigger than
or equal to n plus 1, is
a subset of xk's for k
bigger than or equal to n--
because now I'm-- I have a set
where k's starting at n plus 1.
Here's a set with
k starting at n,
so this is clearly
contained in here.
This implies that
a sub n plus 1,
which is the sup of
the left hand side,
by this little theorem
that I stated here,
is less than or equal to
the sup of the bigger set.
And this is just a sub n.
So we've proven, for all n,
a sub n plus 1 is less than
or equal to a sub n.
OK.
Therefore, this sequence
is monotone decreasing.
OK?
And so this uses the sup part
of this previous theorem,
but if we use the inf
part, then we also get
the statement for the b sub n.
So rather than write
out the details,
I'll leave it to you just to
flip around the inequalities
for the inf in your notes.
So similarly, for all N,
a natural number, b sub n
is bigger than or equal
to b sub n plus 1--
or other way.
OK?
Now, so that shows these
two sequences are monotone.
Now we show they're bounded.
And this follows
simply from the fact
that the x sub n's are bounded.
Since there exist a b
bigger than or equal to 0,
such that all N natural numbers,
x sub n in absolute value
is less than or
equal to b, which
is the same as saying b is--
x sub n is bounded between
minus B and capital B.
So taken as elements
of each of these sets,
if you like this x of k, k
bigger than or equal to n,
that means minus B is
always a lower bound
for these sets and B is always
an upper bound for these sets.
So this implies that
minus B is always
less than or equal to x sub k,
k bigger than or equal to n.
And this always sits
below the supremum.
Since all of these are
bounded above by B,
the supremum has to be
less than or equal to B,
which I'll state in terms of the
a sub n's and b sub n's-- means
minus B is less than or equal
to b sub n is less than or equal
to a sub n is less
than or equal to b.
So these sequences are bounded.
OK?
So in fact, these
two implies that--
all right, so we've shown
that these two sequences
that define--
that we use to define
the limsup and the liminf
are monotone and bounded,
so therefore, the limit
of these two sequences--
the limits, which define
the limsup and liminf,
actually exist.
So limsup and liminf is
always a well-defined object.
Now, this proves one.
To prove two, this
follows immediately
from what we've
proven right here.
So by this part,
we have b sub n is
less than or equal to a sub n.
So for all n, I have
these two sequences,
one sitting below the other.
And last time we proved that
taking the limit respects
inequality, so limit as n
goes to infinity of b sub n--
which is the liminf--
sits below limit as n
goes to infinity of a sub
n, which is the limsup.
And that completes the proof.
So I've shown that these
two objects we defined--
the limsup and the liminf--
exist, and are well-defined
for every bounded sequence.
So this is kind of--
can be a little bit
of a daunting couple
of objects to come
across when you--
especially in your
first analysis class.
So the best thing to
do is look at examples.
Whenever you come
across something
that you just don't
quite understand,
start writing down
some actual things.
So for example, let's again
look at our favorite example
of a bounded sequence
which does not converge,
x sub n equals minus 1 to the n.
Then, if I am looking
at this set x sub n,
n bigger than or equal
to k, and writing--
instead of x sub n,
let me just write
what it is, minus 1 to the n.
So what is this set?
This is just a set consisting
of two elements, 1 and minus 1.
Yeah?
And therefore, the
sup of this set,
which is the sup of
this set, is just 1.
Oops-- so if I take--
which implies that
the limsup of minus 1
to the n, which
is the limit as n
goes to infinity of sup
minus 1 to the n, n bigger
than or equal to the
k-- as we just saw,
this is just the sup of this set
consisting of two elements, 1
and minus 1.
This is equal to the limit as n
goes to infinity of 1 equals 1.
So the limsup of
minus 1 to the n is 1.
Now, if I change all
these sups to infs,
then the inf of
this set is going
to be the inf of this set,
which is just minus 1.
And therefore, we also get--
OK?
So the limsup is 1.
The liminf is minus
1 for this set.
That's just supposed to be a
squiggly line, not necessarily
looking like sigma.
OK, so there's one sequence.
How about our next favorite
sequence, x sub n equals 1/n?
So the set of elements
1/n, such that n
is bigger than or equal--
so 1/k I should write.
Oh, so I was using some--
this should have been a k.
Hope didn't make that
mistake throughout.
No, I kept writing x sub k.
So that should be x sub k.
OK, all of that is
written correctly.
This should have been
minus 1 to the k--
minus 1 to the k.
All right, very good.
So we're looking at now the
set 1 over k, where n is--
where k is bigger
than or equal to n.
So this is just a set 1/n, 1/n
plus 1, 1/n plus 2, 1/n plus 3,
and so on.
OK?
So as I move to the
next entry, things
are getting smaller and smaller.
And in fact, this sequence
just here now, written as--
thinking of this as a new--
so this is not a
sequence-- this is a set.
Taking entries to
be these guys, it's
easy to see that converges to 0.
So anyways, let's say
I take the supremum
of this set, which is what I
need to compute the limsup.
So I'm now taking the
supremum of this set.
1/n plus 1-- that's always
smaller than 1/n, and so
is 1/n plus 2, and
so on and so on.
And 1/n is an element
of the set that's
bigger than or equal to
everything else in the set.
And I think there's an
exercise in the homework
that-- as you just
show, that if you
have a set that contains
an element which
is an upper bound for
the set, then that
has to be the supremum.
So the supremum of
this set is simply 1/n.
OK?
So this supremum
is equal to 1/n.
So as n goes to infinity, the
limit of the supremum here,
which equals the limit as n goes
to infinity of 1/n, equals 0.
OK?
So the limsup of 1/n equals 0.
But now let's say I look
at infs of this set.
So I had to take sups
to look at the limsup.
Now let's say I take infs.
OK?
Now, the inf of
this set-- these are
elements that are getting closer
and closer and closer to 0.
So there's 0, 1/n,
and then they just
keep getting smaller and
smaller and smaller and smaller,
converging to 0.
And you can, in fact, prove
this rigorously if you'd like,
but I think it's easy to
at least convince yourself
that infimum of this
set is equal to 0.
The smallest thing--
so first off, 0
is a lower bound for this set.
And if I take anything
bigger than 0,
that thing cannot be an upper
bound simply because of, if you
like the Archimedean property,
I can always find something from
the set less than that real--
positive real number.
So 0 must be the
least upper bound.
So in summary, the liminf
of 1/n, which is the inf--
the limit as n goes to infinity
of the inf of this set,
is just the limit as n goes
to infinity of 0 equals
0, all right.
So the limsup of 1/n equals 0.
The liminf equals 0 as well.
OK.
So let's take a look at these
two examples a little bit,
and let me just
make a few remarks.
First off, what's to
notice about this sequence
is the fact that
the limsup is 1.
Liminf is equal to minus 1.
So the limsup does
not equal the liminf.
However, in this example,
the limsup, which is 0,
equals the liminf, which is 0.
Now, what's the difference
between these two sequences?
What's the property that one
holds, but the-- one has,
but the other doesn't?
This is a convergent
sequence and this one is not.
And we'll see this
is a general fact,
that if we have a
convergent sequence,
then the limsup and the
liminf equal each other
and are equal to the limit
of the original sequence,
because this sequence
converges to 0.
But that's not just
a one-way street.
It's a two-way street
that, in fact, we'll prove,
if the limsup equals the liminf,
then the original sequence
converges.
So the sequence
converges if and only
if the limsup equals the liminf.
And we saw here that in--
on display, that the
limsup and the liminf
don't equal each other,
and the original sequence,
which we know--
or shown last time--
doesn't converge.
And so one other thing I'd
like to point out is that--
so the limsup of this guy is 1.
The liminf of this
guy is a minus 1.
Now, we can also find a
subsequence which converges
to 1, which is the limsup.
We just take the
entries that we choose
to be the even numbered
entries, and that just gives--
produces a sequence 1.
And that sequence
converges to 1.
If we take the odd
entries of the sequence,
that subsequence is just minus
1 and converges to minus 1,
which is the liminf.
And that's also a
general fact will prove,
that for any bounded
sequence, there
exists some sequences converging
to the limsup and the liminf.
And that will give us the proof
of this Bolzano-Weierstrass
theorem.
All right.
And I think that's all of
the remarks I want to say.
And let me make one
other important comment.
So this sequence, which we use
to define the limsup and also
the liminf--
in three out of
these four cases,
they were actual subsequences.
So the sup of this
set equals 1, which
I can consider as a subsequence
of the original guy--
and the same thing
for the liminf.
The inf of this set
was minus 1, which
I can consider as a subsequence
of minus 1 to the n.
And for the sup of this set,
I got 1/n, which I can--
this is just equal to
the original sequence.
Definitely, I can consider
it as a subsequence
of the original sequence.
But if I take the infimum
of this set, which
I need to define
the liminf, I got 0
for every entry, which
is not a subsequence
of this original sequence.
OK?
So all of that is to say
that the sequences I get
through this process to
define the limsup and liminf
are not necessarily subsequences
of the original sequence.
OK?
What I just said a minute
ago about there actually
being some sequences
which do converge
to the limsup and liminf--
this is a non-trivial fact,
which we're going to prove.
OK.
So theorem-- and this will
give us the Bolzano-Weierstrass
essentially immediately
right after it--
let xn be a bounded sequence.
Then there exists subsequences
xn sub k and xm sub k--
so they don't necessarily have
to be the same subsequence--
such that limit as k goes
to infinity of x sub n sub k
equals the limsup--
so it's a convergent
subsequence--
and the limit as k goes
to infinity of xm sub k
produces the liminf.
OK.
And so before I prove this,
this immediately gives
the Bolzano-Weierstrass
theorem, which
is that every bounded sequence
has a convergence subsequence.
OK.
So again, this
follows immediately
from the previous
theorem, because if I
take a bounded sequence,
by the previous theorem,
I can find a subsequence
which converges
to the limsup, which always
exists for a bounded sequence.
OK?
And then that's [INAUDIBLE].
In fact, we have
something stronger,
in that we have at least
two subsequences which
converge to these two
numbers, which may or may not
be the same.
OK?
So the reason this is so
powerful and so strong
is that it--
to get your hands
on something, it
doesn't require you
to show something
as strong as showing there is
a sequence converging to that.
So quite often, you can think in
terms of variational problems,
where you want to show
that a minimum of something
always exists or a maximum
of something always exists.
Well, what you can try and
do is take a sequence of guys
that you stick into your--
so this is a general nonsense
that you stick into your machine
or function that spits out
output.
And these outputs are
approaching the maximum
or approaching the minimum.
And what you'd like to say
is that there does, in fact,
exist an element that you
can stick into your machine
and produce the maximum
amount of output.
Now, maybe it's not
clear how to do that.
So first, take a
sequence approaching--
so that the values
are approaching that--
the outputs are
approaching the maximum.
Maybe you could show that the
inputs converge to something,
but that's typically
really hard.
But you don't have to work that
hard is what this theorem says.
It says that what you
really need to do,
and which is much more
straightforward, or simpler,
or impossible really, is to show
that that sequence of inputs
that you put into your
machine to get the outputs
is a bounded sequence.
OK?
Then you could pass to a
subsequence, which actually
does converge to
something by this theorem,
and proceed in that way
by showing that you do
have some minimum or maximum--
some input that produces
a maximum output
or minimum output.
So that's a bit small bit of
rambling about why this theorem
is so useful is
that, again, it's--
to get your hands on
something that typically you
want to study,
it's very difficult
to show convergence to that
thing you want to study,
or that thing exists,
because there's a sequence
that you come up with ad
hoc actually converges
to that thing.
But this theorem says you
don't need to work that hard
or try to do the impossible.
And typically, it's
much easier just
to proceed by showing your
sequence of inputs is bounded.
OK, so that's enough of that
bit of rambling about why
this theorem is so useful.
It's also useful in the study
of PDEs, which is what I study.
So I have a soft spot for it.
Actually, one of its
generalizations--
all right, so let's
prove this theorem
that there exists some sequences
which converge to the limsup
and liminf.
So as before, I'm going to
use-- rather than keep writing
the supremum of this set and--
actually, I'm not even
going to do this statement.
I'm going to leave
this as an exercise.
I'm going to do this statement.
I'm going to use this
notation a sub n, as before--
a sub n b sup of x sub k's,
k bigger than or equal to n.
So I want to show that
there's something converging
to the limit as n goes to
infinity of the a sub n's.
And so what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to try up a subsequence
of elements between a sub n
and a sub n minus something
which is converging to 0,
and not quite a sub n.
So it'll be along a
subsequence as well.
So we know that there
exists an n sub 1
bigger than or equal
to 1 simply by how
this is defined as a
supremum, and by the exercise
from assignment 3 that
there exists an n sub 1
bigger than or equal to 1
such that a sub 1 minus 1
is less than or equal to is
less than x sub 1 is less than
or equal to a sub 1.
OK?
All right.
a sub 1 minus 1 is not an upper
bound for the set a sub 1,
which is x sub k's, where k's
bigger than or equal to 1.
Therefore, I should
be able to find
an element from this set
strictly bigger than that.
And of course, it's
always less than
or equal to the supremum,
which is a sub 1.
OK.
So now, since a sub n sub 1 plus
1-- so a sub n sub 1 plus 1,
not 1 plus 1--
since this thing equals
the supremum of xk, such--
k is bigger than or
equal to of 1 plus 1,
there exists an a sub n sub 2--
at least there exists an n sub
2 bigger than n sub 1-- in fact,
it has to be bigger than or
equal to n sub 1 plus 1--
such that a sub n plus 1 minus
1/2 is less than a sub n sub 2
is less than or equal
to a sub n plus 1.
OK?
So why the n sub 1
plus 1 is because I
wanted to obtain a new
entry from the sequence that
comes from farther
than the index n sub 1.
OK?
I'm trying to build
a subsequence.
And like I said, the idea is
I want to somehow sandwich--
this should be x sub n--
I want to build up
a subsequence which
is sandwiched between things
converging to the limsup,
and use the squeeze theorem.
All right?
OK, so since this is
the supremum of this set
that-- and because
this thing is not
an upper bound for
this set, there
exists something from the set--
so some element k bigger than
or equal to n sub 1 plus 1,
which I'm going to call n sub
2, so that x sub
n sub 2 is bigger
than a sub n plus 1 and
a sub n sub 1 plus 1.
And then I just keep doing this.
Since a sub 2 plus 1 equals
the supremum of the x of k,
such that k is bigger than
or equal to n sub 2 plus 1,
there exists an n sub
3 bigger than n sub 2,
such that a sub n sub 2
plus 1, minus now a third,
is less than x sub n sub 3 is
less than or equal to a sub n
sub 2 plus 1.
OK.
But now we're
essentially home free.
We'll just continue
in this manner.
Let me write down.
Now, strictly speaking, I
need to state the construction
of this sequence as
an inductive argument,
but for the purposes
of this class,
I'm not going to do that.
I'm just going to say--
continuing in this manner.
And that will be what
I say for this part.
So continuing in this
manner, we obtain a sequence
of integers, natural numbers--
n sub 1 less than n sub 2
less than n sub 3, so on--
such that what holds--
such that, for all k
[? N, ?] natural number,
a sub n sub k minus
1 plus 1 minus 1/k
is less than or equal
to x n sub k less than
or equal to a sub n
sub k minus 1 plus 1.
OK?
And here, if you like, we didn't
define what n sub 0 is, so--
so really, we're only interested
in the n sub 1, n sub 2.
But for the sake of
this whole thing making
sense for all integers k, with
n sub 0 being defined to be 0--
OK?
That's just the first
case that we dealt with.
So we obtain this
subsequence x sub n sub
k that's sandwiched in between
this subsequence of a's and
minus 1 over k,
and this sequence
of a sub n sub k minus 1.
So since n sub 1 is less
than n sub 2 and so on,
this implies that--
write it this way-- n plus 1 is
less than [INAUDIBLE] 2 plus 1
is less than n sub 3 plus 1.
So this is a subsequence--
a sub n sub k minus 1 plus 1
is a subsequence of a sub n's.
Now, what do we know" We
know the a sub n's converge
to the limsup.
And we proved last time
that every subsequence
of a convergent sequence
converges to the same thing.
That's the limit as k goes
to infinity of a sub n sub
k minus 1 plus 1 equals the
limit of the original sequence,
which is, by
definition, the limsup.
OK?
So now I have this subsequence.
So now I have this
subsequence of x's sandwiched
in between two sequences--
this guy on the left,
this guy on the right.
This guy on the right
converges to the limsup.
This guy on the left converges
to the limsup minus 0,
because 1/k converges to 0.
So by the squeeze theorem,
we get that the limit as k
goes to infinity of x sub n
sub k equals the limit as k
goes to infinity of this
and this whole thing,
which is the limsup.
OK.
And again, so I'll leave it
to you to do the liminf part.
But the point is that
now, basically, this 1/k
gets moved to over here,
and this becomes a sub n sub
k minus 1 plus 1 plus 1/k.
And now I just have this
on sitting below this guy.
All right?
That's really the only
change for the infs
to get a subsequence
converging to the liminf.
OK?
Now, we've shown that there
exists a subsequence converging
to the limsup and
the liminf, which
gives us the
Bolzano-Weierstrass theorem.
And now let me come
back to the statement
I made about these
two sequences here--
namely, that the limsup
equals the liminf if and only
if the original
sequence converges.
So let's prove that now.
Let x sub n be a
bounded sequence.
Then xn converges if and only
if limsup equals the liminf.
And there's one more part.
Moreover, if xn converges,
then all these limits agree--
equals the limsup,
equals liminf.
OK?
So the sequence
converges if and only
if the limsup
equals the liminf--
and in the case that we do have
this limit of the sequences
given by this common value
of the limsup and liminf.
OK, so let's go
in one direction.
To do this direction, we'll
use the squeeze theorem.
So suppose L equals limsup x
sub n equals liminf of x sub n.
We're assuming that these
two things equal each other.
They're given by
a common value L.
And what we're going
to end up showing
is that this sequence
converges to L.
So that actually gives the
second part of the statement
of this theorem here.
So suppose L is this common
number, limsup and liminf.
Then, for all N,
[? a ?] natural number,
we have that the inf
of the x sub k's,
which is for k bigger
than or equal to n--
so x sub n is in this set,
so it's certainly bigger than
or equal to this inf.
And it's less than or equal
to the sup of that set,
again, because x sub
n sits in this set.
All right?
But as n goes to
infinity, this sequence
of numbers converges
to the liminf,
which is L. As n
goes to infinity,
this sequence of numbers
converges to the limsup, which
is L. So by the squeeze
theorem, the thing in between,
which is x sub n,
converges to L.
So for the second part, it's--
follows from what we've proven--
what we proved to obtain
the Bolzano-Weierstrass
and what we know about
convergent sequences
and their subsequences.
So this is for this
direction-- namely,
that convergence implies the
limsup equals the liminf.
Let L be the limit as n
goes to infinity of x sub n.
So now we're assuming that the
sequence converges to something
which we call L-- doesn't
have to be the same L from--
so it's just L I'm just
using for this limit.
By previous theorem, there
exists a subsequence x sub n
sub k, such that
the limit as k goes
to infinity of x sub n sub k
gives me limsup of x sub n.
But this is a subsequence
of a convergent sequence,
and a subsequence of
a convergent sequence
is convergent, and
converges to the same thing.
So this thing on the left
is just equal to L. OK?
Similarly, there exists a
subsequence x sub n sub k,
such that the limit as k goes
to infinity of x sub n sub
k equals liminf of x sub n.
And again, this is a subsequence
of a convergent sequence,
so it's convergent and
convergence of the same thing,
L. So that implies that
this thing is equal to L.
All right.
And therefore, the limsup and
the liminf equal each other,
and they also equal the limit
of the original sequence.
So that is the end of the proof
of this theorem that the limsup
and liminf--
when they coincide and tell
you that the original sequence
converges.
So that's another
way of thinking
about limsups and
liminfs is that they also
somehow measure just how
divergent your sequence is,
or at least the
difference between them.
If that difference is 0,
then your original sequence
is convergent.
OK?
All right, so I think
we'll stop there.